what's going on reject nation late-night
upload I was literally getting ready to
go to bed in my PJs and everything yep
that's right promoting DC stuff in the
middle of this Marvel related thing the
New Mutants trailer dropped Friday the
13th makes sense because this one's
supposed to be more of a horror type of
film Josh Boone's directing it you know
the guy did The Fault in Our Stars when
the scariest movies ever let's check
this out
arias starts supposed to be in this
movie too and Anya Taylor jewelry I'm
gonna ask you a series of questions
yes
have you ever experienced anything in
considered polygraph the architect last
question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Music]
oh hey Giri dangerous that dude from
stranger things
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
you big heart get some rest
[Music]
it should not expected it I heard
they're going more for a horror vibe I
have like serious nipple chills right
now like hardcore I heard that they were
like we want to make this more of a
horror film and for some reason it just
wasn't entirely so loved it I'm like
that sounds so cool and a movie in the
x-men universe that's more like a horror
film I thought it would just be more
like a horror film this looks straight
up like a horror film
the trailer was like creepy and and and
really and scary in a lot of ways it
kind of feels like if Gore Verbinski
directed it this might just be because I
saw a cure for wellness this year some
of the cinematography seems reminiscent
of it i'm alvaro so you guys aren't that
familiar with the New Mutants but I just
think it's so cool that they're making a
legit superhero horror film it makes me
happy to see that the x-men franchise is
doing what I feel like a lot of these
comic-book movies can do one thing I've
always felt is that comic book
characters there's a cinematic universe
with inside of every comic book
character pretty much like the main ones
but especially the x-men the x-men is
something that I don't really care for
the x-men to be part of the MCU directly
because they're proving they can expand
the universe and this if this is done
well I'm gonna be super jacked for them
you know doing a great spin-off like
Logan wisdom doing a great feature istic
spin-off like Logan was awesome you know
the Deadpool's within the x-men universe
and then having this superhero horror
film this looks great you know I know I
compare this to a cure for wellness a
moment ago just because of the
cinematography but I also get some
Kubrick lives which cure for wellness
was inspired by that he gets some of
that Breakfast Club horror movie vibe
you know there's five teenagers but
they're being held against their will so
it's like a horror movie Breakfast Club
type a deal with some Kubrick touches if
they really deal with kind of like
treating these people when they're not
really insane they just don't understand
what mutants are I could kind of see a
little bit of a like One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest type of vibe anya taylor
joy with the witch split and now this i
mean she's on her way to becoming like
one of the most badass scream queens i
think that's the word for it right room
scream queen would you call it that
I don't know hate me in the comics if I
got that wrong this is really exciting
because for a film that's like the 11th
in the x-men franchise this seems like
it'll be a huge treat for fans of the
x-men franchise especially because
they're the ones who have been doing
some r-rated material however I don't
get the impression at all that you need
to see the other x-men films so I feel
like you can be brand new and sort of
just go into this with Legion on TV
doing its own like weird type of sci-fi
thing and then having a horror
I'm so excited with what the x-men
franchise has been doing I mean just
getting like anya taylor joy and Maisie
Williams Arya Stark and I think the kid
from stranger things the dude is like
Charlie he didn't get story of them
having to band together to break out of
this facility but it's like a horror
movie that's so cool I hope this is good
I really hope this is good because I
really did enjoy the trailer a lot that
that was pretty sweet I gotta get up in
like a few hours actually and I have to
drive two hours away to go to an event
so funny thing is that guy from strange
things I think I'm gonna be late to the
strange of things season 2 trailer
because I'm gonna be at this event but
hey I was around to catch New Mutants
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and also check
out our patreon we have a lot of great
stuff over there become a patron is
check today